here's an inequality proof that I've
been asked to show by mathematical
induction proved by mathematical
induction that n factorial is greater
than N squared okay now because we're
dealing with factorials we've got and
being an integer here positive integer
but the person who sent this question to
me didn't give me a domain I didn't say
you know proof for such-and-such a value
now if you go and try out some values
for instance if you try one you like one
factorial that's one and one squared is
also one one greater than one that's not
true and in fact if you try the next
statement you know the next number two
factorial that's two two squared that's
four and that's also not true three is
not true either the first value where
this statement this inequality is
actually true is n is greater than or
equal to four
well N equals four is the first case and
then five six seven and so on it works
just fine okay so the person who's
trying to solve that if you didn't have
that included as part of your question
that might be why you're having
difficulty solving it approving it
because we'll need this fact later on
okay so how does a proof by mathematical
induction usually proceed first let's
test that first allowable value which is
N equals four okay so on my left hand
side I've got four factorial the
definition of factorial is you multiply
by all those previous integers and that
gives me 24 what's my right hand side
that's 4 squared which is 16 so for this
of our value the left hand side is
greater than the right hand side so it's
true for that value okay good establish
that now let's keep going I want to
assume the statement is true for some
arbitrary value K which follows the same
rules as M which I've already set up up
here
so let's actually I'll just I'll just
put in the next line so what does the
statement look like when you put K's in
well you've got this which is greater
than K squared which is true for K
greater than 4 okay now that's what I've
assumed now on the basis of that
assumption I want to prove that it's
true for the next value along k plus 1
okay so that looks like this you put a K
in instead of okay and pretty K plus-1
in there as well this is what I want to
show okay this is where all the work is
going to go now there's a couple
different ways that you can do
inequality proofs one way which I've
showed before is you can start by the by
doing this you know he's right by
assumption and this is your first line
and then you manipulate both sides until
you arrive at something either this or
something equivalent to that okay now in
this particular case I don't think
that's the most direct way or the
fastest or most obvious way here's a way
that will be helpful okay have a look at
this now you can see that just by it's
simple simply moving some terms around
that this inequality is sorry that
should be a factorial is equivalent to
this inequality
okay all I've done is moved this term
over here onto the left hand side now
the reason why it's it's probably more
useful to us is that it's easier to
prove that something anything is
positive than it is to prove that two
arbitrary things are one's bigger than
the other or the other way around okay
so I'm gonna work with this this guy
here on the left hand side let's
consider this other way consider what I
had there on the left hand side namely K
plus 1 factorial minus k plus 1 all
squared okay let's think about this know
if I just take out well if I rewrite
this so I can take out a factor make it
a little more obvious that K plus 1
factorial is K plus 1 by a K factorial
right and then I've got my K plus 1 all
squared here okay so let me take out a
factor of k plus 1 what that's going to
leave me with is K factorial K plus 1
there okay now this is crucially
important here that I factorize this out
because now you can see that what I've
got is my other color here is what I've
got in here this K factorial right that
appeared in my assumption it appeared
here right I'm going to use my
assumption which was that K factorial in
K squared
and I'm gonna sub it out here okay so I
know well I'm assuming you know by
assumption that this is bigger than K
squared so that means this statement is
now true okay so that K factorial I'm
gonna put in for a K squared and that
equality sign here I'm gonna change for
an inequality sign
now I'm gonna expand this that's minus K
minus 1 okay now what have I got here
I've by assumption from this line to
this line
I should really write but I sort of run
out of space here bye
[Music]
okay I've used the fact that K factorial
should be between K squared so this line
is bigger than this line okay now this
is a little more useful to me because I
can play around with this algebraically
right for instance this here I can
complete the square and I can factorize
it and show something useful about it
okay so for instance if you go like this
you know k plus 1 times now have a look
at this that K squared minus K I can
complete the square if you sent me this
question you don't know how to complete
the square or if you're out then you're
like I have no idea what that mean just
let me know in a comment and I'll um
I'll show you how to complete the square
as a separate video but so far basically
all you have to do is you want to add
and subtract a number which will make
this easy to factorize as a perfect
square okay so I've added 1/4 subtracted
across there's no change really there
that minus 1 comes from the previous
line okay so now this allows me to
factorize one two three these terms here
as K minus 1/2 all squared okay that
minus 1/4 nut minus one that's minus 5
on 4 ok now this is what I've got so far
now this doesn't look like it's any use
to us but actually it's very very useful
because I can say but you know K is
greater than or equal to 4 that's one of
the conditions I set on this number ok
so I'm going to try and move from this
to this and make some conclusions about
it right so K minus 1/2 that's what
got there if you subtract half from both
sides you get three and a half okay if I
square both sides which should you have
to be careful with with inequalities but
here it's going to be fine it should be
greater than twelve and a quarter right
and now if I subtract the 5 on 4 over
here K minus 1/2 or squared minus 5 on 4
sorry that should be greater than or
equal to 11 okay which means that you
know this number is a pretty big number
right like the smallest it can possibly
is a B is 11 and depending on the value
of K it could be other kinds of you know
bigger numbers right so therefore this
number certainly must be positive right
K minus 1/2 squared minus 5 on 4 surely
is greater than 0 because it's greater
than 11 right which is way bigger than 0
right now did you see what that means
right I can take this and I can also
notice that you know because K is
greater than or equal to 4 then k plus 1
is greater than or equal to 5 so k plus
1 is greater than 0 now what have I got
here take these two important lines here
this one and this one right now if I've
got those two right if either this being
a positive number and this being a
positive number
well I don't know how big they are but
if I multiply them together like so then
surely the product of two positive
numbers is also positive right see what
I've done there okay now come back to
what the reason why I was talking about
this right it's because what I have here
is what I have here on the right hand
side right and that's K plus 1 factorial
minus k plus 1 all squared okay which is
which is greater than this okay so let's
put it all together let's see if I can
fit it on the page okay on the left hand
side the most left hand side I've got K
plus 1 factorial minus k plus 1
squared well that's greater than k plus
one outside of this Rideau factorize
thing I've got K minus 1/2 squared minus
5 on 4 but I just spent all this time in
read write doing the algebra to show
that that product this particular
product must be positive right it's
greater than 0 so here's what I've got
so far so this is greater than this and
this is greater than this
well therefore I can sort of forget
about this middleman right because I can
just say well this guy on the left hand
side must clearly be positive right
because it's bigger than a number which
is positive so that once means it must
be positive as well so now I can use
that and bring this guy back over the
other side which is the statement I was
trying to prove all the way back a
couple of pages ago right this is the
statement for N equals k plus 1 right so
I can say therefore statement is true
for N equals k plus 1 provided you know
it's true for N equals K that was our
assumption right provided it is true for
N equals ok ok so since it is true for
we I just evaluated it for N equals 4
therefore it must be true for all the K
plus ones after that right 4 5 6 and so
on right ie is greater than equal to 4
and there's the proof